[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
harvey weinstein pleads not guilty to 11
rape and sexual assault allegations the
disgraced hollywood producer
now convicted rapist extradited from new
york to california
digging deeper into new information
released in the lori vallo and chad day
bell investigation
a grandparent's heartbreaking efforts to
find her grandson now believed to be
murdered by the doomsday couple
plus the police chase of a suspect
accused of murdering a college student
who allegedly got into his car
thinking it was her uber ride get over
here hey
the trial of the k-stop brought
nationwide attention to the need for
rideshare safety
and sentencing in the fake pizza
delivery murder case erica stefanko
begging a judge for leniency
i would like to be back with my family
someday law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
convicted rapist and disgraced hollywood
producer harvey weinstein
pled not guilty to rape and sexual
assault charges in los angeles
his attorneys say some of those charges
should be dropped immediately
weinstein is facing 11 charges in los
angeles four counts of rape
seven counts of sexual assault the
charges are related to incidents
involving five women at beverly hills
hotels between 2004
and 2013. that's on behalf of your
clients away formal reading of the
indictment advisement of rights
interim not guilty denying all special
obligations enhancements
and or priors yes the not guilty plea is
entered
weinstein was extradited from a new york
state prison on tuesday
where he is serving a 23-year sentence
for rape and sexual assault
if convicted in la weinstein facing up
to 140 years in prison
now his defense is asking a judge to
dismiss three of the charges against him
they claim the statute of limitations
has expired for accusations on those
counts
your honor i've submitted a request for
medical evaluation mr weinstein
he's due back in court next week
terry weinstein is finally in california
how this how will this case play out
and will him be incarcerated on the new
york case affect the cali case
well you know there are a lot of moving
parts here he was convicted back in
february of 2020 in the new york case
and as you know he's serving
a 23-year prison sentence he argued for
a long time
against this extradition now he's in
california
and he has to face these charges and as
you said he could face up to 140 years
in prison but they have that case on an
expedited schedule
and they're going to skip some pre-trial
hearings
and the next hearing for the case is
going to be
in july july 29th so i think it's going
to move quickly
and i think we're going to see something
occur and
then obviously he's going to have to
serve his sentence back in new york
and then if he's convicted serve here as
well and for our viewers don't forget
those charges were laid down
during the new york trial so they've
been pending for some time he's just
been fighting extradition so part of the
reason
why this is going to be expedited thank
you terry now to the doomsday cult
couple case where a trove of emails show
how a grandmother frantically tried to
find her grandson
chad daybel and lori valodebel are
charged with killing her children
and his wife and jeanette levy has more
from the newly released documents
brian k woodcock was j.j vallo's
biological grandmother these emails show
just how incredibly concerned she was as
she reached out to investigators
when she couldn't find or reach j.j valo
or his older step-sister tyler ryan
her religious stuff has gone way off
deeper that was charles valo in 2019
trying to get help for his wife lori
valo laurie's brother
alex cox shot and killed charles months
later in july claiming self-defense
prosecutors now say cox who died later
that year
conspired with his sister to kill
charles
charles value's sister k woodcock became
increasingly concerned about jj
when she couldn't get in touch with him
through lori
emailed detectives in chandler arizona
after jj was last seen alive
saying laurie moved out of state she
wrote this has substantially heightened
my concern for jj's well-being
woodcock sent another email to
detectives in november 2019
saying she logged into her brother's
amazon account and found searches for
beach wedding dresses
and extra-large men's white linen pants
detectives later recovered a photo from
lori's icloud
showing a man's hand with a wedding band
on a woman's backside
the woman wearing a wedding dress when
chad dabell and lori valo went to hawaii
investigators kept tabs on them setting
up a camera that captured images of them
outside of a home meanwhile
investigators wrote about audio they
found on laurie vallo's phone from
february 2019
entitled laurie's testimony a detective
wrote
she is self-prophesying and everything
she does is because her heavenly father
tells her earlier this year lori valo
dabel and chad dabel were charged with
the murders of jj valo
tylie ryan and chad's wife tammy the
children's bodies were found last year
buried in chad daybel's yard how do you
have two kids in your backyard
and you don't know anything about it and
it's just
i know it's the justice system but
anyway now lori valodebel is currently
receiving
mental health treatment after a court
found that she was not competent to
stand trial in idaho
investigators say in these emails when
they're writing back and forth to one
another
that the evidence clearly shows that
there was premeditation
on the parts of both uh valo de bell and
chad dabo
brian thanks aunt jeanette joining us
today is retired detective and swap
member at lisa lockwood
let's jump right in and jeanette it
looks like k woodcock was
really helpless in this situation right
oh she was completely helpless and it
was really heartbreaking to read through
these emails because she was
constantly emailing the investigators
and trying to bring things to their
attention
she had been very concerned obviously as
her brother had been
charles valo who who told investigators
back in january of 2019 that laurie
debell or lori vallo at that point was
saying she was going to kill him because
she felt that he was a zombie
so k woodcock was very concerned
especially after her
brother's murder and that only
intensified as the months wore on
absolutely now lisa you're familiar with
detective work how do the police go from
concerned grandmother to angenette
having to read 2500 documents
right it's true the first indication
that she thought something was up when
she wasn't able to get in touch with
lori and she felt that she was being
ostracized
for receiving the insurance policy from
her brother's death
so she thought she was upset by that and
it was i think something's fishy here i
think they may have been responsible for
it
let's look into this a little bit
further she even wanted a well-being
check
investigators need to look at all that
information and go forward with it and
try to find out why is there suspicion
regarding this
what we do know is the the clothing that
he's wearing right now in this photo the
red pajamas
that was the last time that he was seen
alive and he was also found
buried in that same outfit which was six
weeks later when he officially went off
the radar and he was last seen
a lot of information we're sifting
through so far of course as we said
before
chad day bell is going to be tried first
laurie vallo dave bell is still
being found incompetent to stand trial
so i'll wait to see if she becomes
competent in the near future but until
then we'll keep eyes on this case
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily the fake pizza delivery
order that ended in murder
find out how much time erica stefanco
will spend behind bars
but first the stop the chase and the
arrest of a suspect accused of murdering
a college student who got into his car
thinking he was her uber driver more on
the trial of nathan roland
next
[Music]
welcome back a south carolina man
accused of fleeing from police
is now on trial for the murder of a
college student who allegedly got into
his car
thinking it was her uber ride
27 year old nathaniel roland is charged
with kidnapping and murdering 21 year
old samantha josephson
josephson was last seen on surveillance
video around 2 a.m
in march 2019 getting into the backseat
of a car
she thought was her uber her body was
found 14 hours later
stabbed 30 times later that day police
say they found roland's vehicle
matching the suspect's description but
he ran when they pulled him over
officers say they searched his vehicle
where they found incriminating evidence
a cell phone and a set of keys can you
describe the cell phone
um an iphone uh i think was waiting or
found any color and
a set of keys with a pink key chain on
it or key ring on
did you then continue to look throughout
the car a little bit
additionally from there yes for
marijuana being it was a strong odor
i didn't think the little bit of shake
was going to be the source of the odor
why didn't you search the car more
thoroughly at that point
um there is lots of that inside the car
there's
obviously something severe took place
inside the car
that didn't be processed by
professionals our crime scene techs so
that's when we backed out didn't want
we wanted to preserve as much evidence
as possible when you see it when you
said it was obvious i mean
what if anything did you observe large
quantities of blood
footprints on the window cleaning
supplies bleach
the victim did order an uber ride but
her actual driver couldn't find her
her boyfriend and friends searched
everywhere until police said
they found her body i called her while i
was
on the way there but she never answered
the phone so i circle around the block i
always give them like
about five to ten minutes because you
know they they be here and there they
won't really be at the spot where
they're supposed to be
okay so i rolled around for a minute i
called her again
nobody answered the phone and then once
you get to your destination
after so many minutes it'll come up as
cancel your ride if your rider didn't
show up
okay you know and so when i was riding
i waited the council thing showed up i
think i circled like two or three times
okay but i never i never got in contact
with her never saw her so he said cancel
your ride
and i just hit counsel they led us into
what i would call a conference room and
there were
mr mrs josephson sitting there looking
distraught
i the first thing that went through my
head was i hope their look is just
because they haven't found her yet as
you said or as i confirmed they hadn't
told me
what had actually happened yet um they
broke the news to us right there
um and
just after that you know i just broke
down felt my legs collapsed from under
me and
you know just kind of black you almost
black out
just with disbelief back with us is
retired detective and swat member lisa
lockwood and terry austin
terry the prosecution's first witnesses
kind of painted a picture of what was
going on
and the defense didn't cross-examine
them all what do you make of that choice
i thought it was a very smart move first
of all it was smart for the prosecution
to put greg the boyfriend
on because he established a couple of
things he established the timeline
and he established the fact that they
were in very close contact he and
samantha
they talked to each other all the time
and they had to find your friend app
on their phone but i think the real
reason that the defense
did not cross is because there was
nothing the defense could say
here as far as this witness was
concerned he's not going to be able to
say that they weren't close and the
timeline is the timeline so smart move
on both the prosecution and the defense
as far as this witness is concerned
absolutely not lisa the car is a big
part of the evidence in this case
how do you think the investigation into
roland's car was handled do you see any
strong points in their search and
maybe any weak points i do
primarily strong points the police
officer who was actually on the scene
who pulled over
nathaniel he was the initial officer who
investigated and started the search
and what he disclosed what he found a
telephone keys
blood cleaning supplies and then
ultimately a footprint
on one of the inside windows once he saw
that all bets were off and when he was
being examined he said he stopped and
the reason being is because
officers on the street are not trained
for crime scene investigation
to make the proper analysis of
everything so he needed to seal it up
stop touching everything preserve the
evidence
and later on they were able to find that
it did belong to
samantha absolutely a lot of that
information is the thrust of the
prosecution's case
the thrust of why they believe he's
guilt and i think the biggest concern
for the defense
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily hear from young athletes who
say
they were assaulted by their own coaches
as big organizations
looked the other way plus the courtroom
drama that got robber durst up on his
feet
the latest in the murder trial of the
millionaire real estate air
after the break
[Music]
welcome back more fireworks in the
courtroom during the robert durst trial
this time it was enough for the
defendant to stand up up out of his
wheelchair
robert durst is on trial for the
december 2000 murder of his best friend
susan berman
the trial began last march with a long
pause due to the pandemic
your honor well one second wait talk to
mr chess now first
prosecutors say they expect to rest
towards the end of next week the defense
will call witnesses immediately after
robert dares expected to testify and
told his attorney he would like to do so
without a mask on
a testify without wearing a mask okay
we'll bring that up to him
durst is facing him to life in prison
the start of the olympics is right
around the corner and these athletes are
feeling the pressure
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross is digging into allegations
that some were sexually abused thanks
brian coming up this week on brian ross
investigates
with the olympics very much in the news
we're taking another look at a troubling
story about young american athletes
and allegations they've been sexually
abused by their coaches and major
organizations have tried to cover it up
and i trusted him just like you were
saying is i trusted him with
my game and my future my college degree
but borges who ran a tennis foundation
for young boys in northern california
and was thought of as a charismatic
leader had a
dark secret he was successful not only
grooming stevie and his family but the
entire
community around him and that's the
primary reason why he was so
successful at doing what he really
wanted to do which was molest children
i was i was sexually abused by this
coach um
from the time i was about 13 to about 15
or so
that's this week on brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network brian
thanks brian ross when we come back
sentencing day for erica stefanko the
fake pizza delivery order that costs an
army veteran her life
the x verse x versus x courtroom battle
next
welcome back an ohio woman was sentenced
to spend the rest of her life
in prison for a deadly plot involving a
fake pizza delivery order
army veteran ashley biggs was murdered
in 2012. her ex-boyfriend chad cobb pled
guilty
then turned in his ex-wife erica
stefanco
prosecutors say biggs and cobb were in a
custody battle over their daughter
at the time biggs was working as a pizza
delivery driver
cobbs and stefanko were convicted of
using biggs's job to lure her into a
closed business with a fake order
then cobb killed her and the children of
the defendant and the victim was in the
back seat of the car
when this all went down
the night of the murder i can still
remember you using a fake name to order
the pizza to lure my mother into her
death trap
he had so much jealousy of
so much jealousy of and hatred towards
my mom that not only did you rob me and
my mother but also my dad
why is it that my dad bought airfare to
disney world but you were conspiring
behind his back to do this to my mom
we can never expose the monster you are
and the harm you caused me because in
your words we need to be on the same
page
or you would take my family away from me
even my siblings
even your own mother once stated that
you had a very dark side
now your reign of terror has come to an
end we pray bars hold you for the rest
of your lifetime
as we have seen what befalls those that
cross your path
the present cannot change the past but
maybe the future can
use some of the pain and holes in lives
and offer some closure for us
all you have made your bed now it is
your turn to lie in it
and the defender herself spoke giving a
tearful statement to the court
before she was sentenced by the judge
your honor if it is
healing and helpful
to ashley's family and friends
to grace think of being as the monster
if it is helpful for cindy khan
to exonerate her child for his own
actions by putting the blame on me
if that helps these people particularly
people who are victims
i can accept that
i was most certainly my worst self
during my relationship with chad
i have never been a hateful person
i would never have wanted what happened
to ashley biggs
regardless of what statements people
think that they heard on that tape
the state of ohio has elected to
sentence and move forward on sentencing
on the conviction of aggravated murder
prior to committing the offense the
defender had not been convicted of
or pleaded guilty to a criminal offense
prior to committing the offense the
offender had led a law-abiding life
for a significant number of years
the offense was committed under
circumstances
not likely to reoccur the offender shows
genuine remorse for the offense the
court is issuing a life sentence with
parole eligibility after
30 years
lisa what was your take on the victim
impact statements and did you feel the
judge's sentence
fit their sentiments i do it was more
than
the minimum and you did hear the victim
impact statement from her stepdaughter
who was abused from erica from this
woman
who said i don't have a hateful bone in
my body but yet we do know and everybody
heard in that court along with the judge
that she was physically abused she was
threatened she was jealous
of her relationship with her dad and she
also fed her dog feces
so i know the judge is aware of that so
when she wrote her pre-written
decision she was going to go for the
maximum definitely something in the back
of her head while making that decision
terry eligible for parole after 30 years
is that the right sentence and do you
think stefanko's words helped at all
i do think it's the right sentence and i
don't think the words made any
difference to the judge
as lisa just said we know for a fact
that the judge already had her
sentencing in mind and she was going for
the higher amount it's a heinous crime
it's a planned crime
the defendant is 38 right now and so 30
years will make her
68 years old if in fact she gets out for
parole
at that time so i think it's a very long
sentence and i think it's a
worthy sentence and you know i feel as
though she's accepted responsibility and
it was good that she did say some words
and
it may have given the family some
comfort
but that's not enough she knew what she
was doing
it was you know a very difficult crime
against an innocent woman and you
shouldn't
get the death penalty in
fact when you're having a custody battle
with your ex-spouse so
i think that all in all the right
conviction was made and the right
sentence was made here
yeah by the judge's word it seemed that
she balanced the fact that she had no
criminal history that she lived
like she said a law abiding life before
this but just the
extent of the planning was so huge and
the fact that someone was murdered and
children
lost their mother definitely something
to consider thank you both for joining
us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you